All right, Crawley here again. Let's talk about the heavy construction phase.
If we are building a massive infrastructure asset, we have to know the difference between CAR and EAR.
CAR stands for Contractors All Risk insurance.
This policy primarily covers civil works. Think concrete, steel, and physical structures like constructing hospitals, roads, bridges, or warehouse complexes.
For CAR, my coverage starts the moment the construction materials are unloaded at the site, and it expires the day the building is taken over or put into service.
But what if the project isn't a concrete warehouse shell?
What if I am installing the actual machinery inside, like automated conveyor systems, power generators, manufacturing lines, or steam boilers?
That requires EAR, Erection All Risk insurance.
EAR shifts the primary focus away from the concrete and onto the electromechanical works.
And here is the crucial distinction you'll need for the upcoming quiz.
EAR automatically covers any minor civil work components needed to install those machines.
More importantly, EAR natively provides cover for the high-risk testing and commissioning phase for brand new machinery to ensure they don't explode when first plugged in.
A CAR policy can cover electromechanical testing, too, but only if I explicitly pay extra to add it via a special endorsement.
Both policies use a broad insuring proviso that protects against sudden and unforeseen physical losses that aren't specifically excluded, like an accidental fire, a landslide, or a worker accidentally dropping a heavy engine component during assembly.
Just remember, CAR is for the structural shell, and EAR is for the operational mechanical muscle.
Next up, we look at what happens when the building is finished and filled with sensitive silicon.